simply going to dash towards the left
side of the board you can see prague
getting braver yeah craig was about to
take his headset off there he's about to
resign
uh yeah the black king is just marching
that way one pawn on the right half will
distract the white king and the white
rook the other black pawns will win the
game and prague just meditating he knows
this game is gone he needs to win the
next one now is he already starting to
forget about it do you think i think
he's trying it won't be easy but uh he's
a very very mature player
um i really liked his attitude like when
he was interviewed before the match he's
not going to think about the other
matches he said he's just going to
concentrate on this one uh which is
completely the right way to go but you
know he's got black in the next game um
and
looked like a niche played very well
here he kind of needs an off-form
a niche and there he goes he's he's
resigned now it is over
a loss for pragnanda in the first game
to anish giri and that means he has to
make a comeback at some point he wants
to win his match in the rapid portion
today